if you look at 2021 and beyond we're in
the age of the informed consumer
and anybody that wants to deny that is
fundamentally going to be left behind
there's no question about it and so it
doesn't matter the way you used to do it
the way your daddy or mommy did it the
only thing that matters is where's the
marketplace headed and are we willing to
get in front of the marketplace that's
the essence that they ask you answer and
that's why we should talk about these
things and besides again i gotta stress
if you don't talk about it they're gonna
learn it they're gonna learn from
somebody else so may as well be you
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community-driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders today i'm
joined by marcus chiriden co-owner and
partner of impact
marcus is a highly sought after
international keynote speaker known for
his unique ability to excite engage and
motivate audiences he is co-owner and
partner at impact one of the most
successful digital sales and marketing
agencies in the country and author of
they ask you answer once touted by
mashable as the number one marketing
book dub a web marketing guru by the new
york times and in 2017 named one of 20
speakers you don't want to miss by
forbes his philosophy has helped
countless marketing and sales teams
around the world connect with buyers
online and achieve astounding revenue
growth in fact marcus saved his swimming
pool company river pools and spas from
the economic collapse of 2008 and
adapted not only to stay afloat but to
thrive
alright marcus sheridan welcome to 20
minute leaders how are you
michael great to be here i got a feeling
we're gonna have a great conversation i
was just about to say the same thing
we're already on the same page here
where are you calling from
virginia today
yeah virginia but you know you never
know where it's going to be
and because i travel
uh
for speaking full-time right except
during pandemics at which point i just
sit on zoom calls all day long right but
uh i'm happy that we're moving past that
and uh that that the world is opening
back up definitely okay so next episode
is going to be in person i'll catch you
somewhere in the world and but for now
we'll do it we'll do it this way you're
highly sought after international a
keynote speaker and you're also part of
a co-owner and partner at impact which
you'll tell me and very very soon
talking about digital sales and
marketing agencies you're the author of
they ask you answer uh touted by
mashable as number one marketing book a
lot of other amazing amazing quotes and
so obviously we're going to be talking
about today digital sales and marketing
and which which i feel is just a little
bit a little bit relevant to 2021 and
and where we are with society just a
tiny tiny bit so marcus you know before
we get to that walk me a little bit
through your journey and and
what what are the moments that led you
to understand that this is really where
your passion lies
well you know for me it all started um
right out of college
i thought i was going to
work near dc and i didn't like the area
and so i came back home
to the country where i live in virginia
my two buddies had just started a
swimming pool company
and they said hey do you wanna work in
the swimming pool company
and i said well until i find out what
i'm gonna do with my life yeah sure
and so i jumped in with them and six
months later they said hey would you be
a partner in this business
and so nobody ever you know grows up
saying i want to be a pool guy but i
became a pool guy essentially at age 22.
and
you know we fought to grow the business
but by 2008 when the market collapsed we
were in big trouble and i thought we
were gonna have to file bankruptcy and
that's when i started to really learn
about the internet
learn about things like you know content
marketing social media blogging you know
stuff that we've heard many times by
this point and
you know what i heard in my simple pool
guy in mind was
you know marcus if you just obsess over
your customers questions and you're
willing to address them on your website
you just might save your business
and so i said well shoot that's one
thing i can do i can
i can address my customers questions i
can do well i you know i teach pretty
well so
that's what we're gonna do and we
i
i brainstormed all the questions i had
received over the years hundreds of
questions
and then i proceeded to answer them one
by one
on my website through articles and
videos over the next couple years and we
became the most trafficked swimming pool
website in the world
and uh it was it was amazing what was
happening and so i said you know what
other people should know
about what i'm doing here is this stuff
this works
and so i started a blog
uh that was separate where i just
started talking about what i was doing
with my business
and
that led to companies reaching out
saying hey can you teach us how to do
that
and that led to speaking engagements
that eventually led to me writing the
book which is they ask you answer
and now they ask you answer has been
embraced by companies all over the world
and we have
i have an agency and i speak and that's
the quick journey but i tell you what it
all started michael with this mindset of
what does my customer want well they
want me to answer their questions am i
willing to do it yeah i'm willing to do
it that's really where it started
so it sounds very you know it sounds
trivial somebody's asking you know
customers are asking questions you know
obviously as a seller you want to answer
them why why is this
why is this not trivial
yeah so it's just great in principle
it's very
trivial in practice
it's
not and so
why is this well
if you talk to most companies and you
say do you want to be the voice of trust
in your space they'll say yeah i'd like
to be seen as the voice of trust
but when it comes down to it most aren't
willing to pay the price and what is the
price starts with the obsessive
listening
of your customers understanding their
issues worries concerns fears etc
and then
going beyond that
addressing those very specific things
that they want to know and in fact in
the book michael we talk about five
subjects that buyers are obsessed with
that they want to know you and me as
consumers buyers we always research
businesses though they don't want to
talk about these five things and i'll
tell you the five
as buyers are obsessed with how much
does it cost we want an all about cost
price rates etc
as buyers were obsessed with what are
the problems with it or the negatives or
the issues or the drawbacks right
when we are researching something when
we want to buy something we want to know
how could it blow up in our face right
what could go wrong so second one's
problems
as buyers we're obsessed with
comparisons we love to compare stuff
online dude i mean we are constantly
comparing things online as buyers we're
obsessed with reviews that's number four
and number five for obsessed with best
think about all the times you've gone
online and search for best such and such
so we've got cost problems comparisons
reviews and best
that literally runs the economy in terms
of the way buyers like you and i
research yet businesses
don't like to talk about these things
michael especially if they're service
based businesses b2b
manufacturers
all that stuff and now all of a sudden
we have a problem of trust because
they're not addressing what everybody
wants to know
and why don't they like to talk about
this stuff
you know i like to compare it with the
ostrich with it said in the sand it
thinks the problem is going to go away
but it doesn't ever go away right
you know when it comes to this digital
world that we're now in michael
ignorance is not bliss
and there was a time
when
companies didn't have to talk about this
because the buyer just couldn't get it
immediately elsewhere
but now they can
and you know
one of the reasons why we say we don't
do these things let's take cost and
price for example michael there's three
main reasons why companies don't talk
about cost and price on their website
first reason is they say well every job
is different and so therefore it depends
yeah that's really easy to talk about
actually because you can talk about why
it's more expensive in other words what
drives cost up what keeps costs down why
are some companies expensive why are
some companies cheap you really get to
teach the marketplace what defines value
proposition but the thing about that one
is if you don't teach it who will
somebody else
and ignorance is what commoditizes a
product or service
knowledge is what decommoditizes so the
first reason why we don't like talk
about cost and price is because we say
it depends the second reason is we say
well we tend to be more expensive and if
we're more expensive we might scare them
away which is totally stupid because the
thing that actually scares us away is
buyers is when we're on a website we're
researching something and we cannot find
information on it and the quickest way
to understand this is let's say somebody
said to you hey michael have you heard
about such and such restaurant you're
like oh no i haven't they're like you
gotta check it out you gotta go you know
bring a friend bring a loved one
whatever and you're like okay i'll check
it out and so you decide to go before
you go you go online you look at reviews
you're like reviews seem okay but you go
to their you go to their website you
look at the menu like so many people do
and there's no pricing on the menu
now what's wild about this is in that
moment the majority of people do not go
to that restaurant any longer and it's
not because they can't afford it it's
because
the moment
they leave it blank they plant a seed of
doubt on the menu and when seeds of
doubt exist inertia occurs and we don't
take action we stop so that's the second
reason why we don't talk about cost and
price is because we're afraid we're
going to scare them away when it's the
opposite what scares them away is
ignorance and the third reason why we
don't like to talk about cost and price
is we say things like well our
competitors will find out which is
totally ridiculous because if you go to
anybody that's been in the industry for
any period of time and you say do you
have a pretty good sense of what your
competitors charge they're going to say
yes of course i do and so if you have a
good sense as to what your competitors
charge it means they have a good great
sense as to what you charge this is the
big secret non-secret everybody acts
like nobody knows what everybody's
charging when in reality everybody does
you see this is the stuff that we see
all the time yet if you take most let's
say service based b2b businesses michael
90 to this day don't talk about cost and
price on their website it's crazy
amazing tangibly when when you're
talking to organizations when you're
working with with other leaders of
organizations thinking through this
does this do they get it once once they
understand this or do you find that
there is some reluctance to to just wrap
their mind around what's happening here
there's resistance until i force them to
look at the mirror and say hey
what would you want as a buyer
because this is the problem
you become a world-class marketer the
moment you become incredibly self-aware
as to your evolving behaviors online
but what's so wild michael is that so
many people don't even recognize how
they themselves are changing every
single day
what you expect and so these same
business owners and leaders that are
pushing back on trends are the very ones
responsible for the trends in the first
place right it's really wild
and so i've had a lot of success
convincing uh businesses to do this i've
had entire industries talk a lot more
about cost and price because you know
i've started you know i've been speaking
now for about 10 years i've really
embedded myself in certain industries
and revolutionized a lot of these
industries because the fact of the
matter is
that
we you know if you look at 2021 and
beyond we're in the age of the informed
consumer
and anybody that wants to deny that is
fundamentally going to be left behind
there's no question about it
and so it doesn't matter the way you
used to do it the way your daddy or
mommy did it the only thing that matters
is where's the marketplace headed and
are we willing to get in front of the
marketplace that's the essence of the
ask you answer and that's why we should
talk about these things and besides
again i gotta stress if you don't talk
about it they're gonna learn it they're
gonna learn it from somebody else so it
may as well be you i i love the idea
that we're in the era of the informed
consumer i think that that's that's
that's a really really nice way of
looking at where the market is heading
now for for young entrepreneurs that are
starting out their journey starting
companies whether it be in tech and
service and b2b whatever it may be
how how tangibly does does you know a
young ceo come in and
nurture a culture
that that absorbs this type of behavior
that obsessively wants to answer the
customer's questions being over
communicative and extra informative
well let me tell you one way you don't
do it is you don't say hey let's be
great at content marketing
because
that ain't going to move the needle and
unfortunately that's what a lot of
marketers say
that's why it doesn't resonate marketers
fight to get buy-in all day long
partly because leadership teams and
sales can be hard-headed
uh partly though because they themselves
are terrible at explaining marketing in
a way that resonates with sales and
leadership
and so this is
absolutely key now it's also why
if you're a leader you say to your
organization what's our vision our
vision is let's be the best teachers in
the world
let's obsess over our customers
questions
let's become the voice of trust that's
our goal
now if you approach it that way that was
just a beautiful marketing strategy that
i just suggested to you but i didn't use
marketing phrases or terms right and
that's when we talk about mission
statements and vision and all that other
stuff that's the way you got to do it
because otherwise it doesn't land with
your entire team you've got to use
shared language
not departmental language
right and it sounds to me like this is
also something that is not
simply relevant to to the marketers of
the organization right you have maybe
you have the r d departments and you
have the you have you have the content
in the marketing organizations but this
is something more in the culture that
you have to instill in anybody that is
working on a product that services other
people to both be cognizant of the of
the flaws that we have with us that were
coming in from the previous generations
or the previous industries but also as a
way of thinking of how are we developing
our products
while being while at answering those
questions that the customers are asking
right
i love that because if you if you're
doing product development you've got to
be willing to say so if i had to pick
this product apart what would i hate
about it what would fresh me about it
frustrate me about what would annoy me
about it what if anything
uh could i change
and you know when you approach it that
way it's it's
it's like you know don't think about
your buyer think like your buyer that is
the that is the key
and
truly putting yourself
in their shoes companies say they do
this no they don't they don't do this
because otherwise like let me give you a
silly example
how many attorneys do we have in the
world like millions and how many of them
address on their website what happens if
you lose your case none
none now how many people are thinking
what happens if i lose my case every
single one but you see any attorneys
talking about this no
see that's that's ridiculous it doesn't
make any sense because everybody's
thinking the same thing again ignorance
is not bliss
right and so with your you're the
co-owner and partner of impact how does
it how do you actually work with others
to resolve these issues because because
besides the speaking engagements where
where you're going with the principles
here you actually have to go and drill
down into the actual culture and the
actual problems that an organization
might have what what is that what does
that process look like from an outsider
coming in
you know
i think the whole marketing agency model
is totally screwed up and broken
and what i mean by that is
when i look ahead
the future of the internet and business
success is not going to be
decided
by you outsourcing
your content your voice the soul of your
business
so my agency teaches companies how to
own
their content production their video
production
how to integrate
sales and marketing
so that they're essentially one revenue
team
and this model isn't easy for a lot of
companies at first but it is by far the
most productive if you want to change an
industry and you see at this point in my
career michael all i'm interested in is
world-class case studies
i think just doing a campaign for
somebody is so boring what i want is to
see someone like a business
turn their industry on its head
and you don't do that by following the
rules that everybody else has followed
you certainly don't do that by
outsourcing all your content
show me one company that became the
voice of their industry by outsourcing
all their content
i ain't never seen it it doesn't exist
and so if you want to become the river
pools of your space you do like i did
you produce your own stuff because it's
your voice you're the subject matter
expert you leverage your team of subject
matter experts and you get it done that
way and that's how you tell a story
that's how you do it but you don't do it
by outsourcing and so we're the
anti-outsourcing agency we teach you how
and train you how to do these things and
it's a beautiful model and uh and it's
you want to talk about empowering it's
incredibly empowering
it sounds like it and it sounds like you
get to do some pretty fun stuff and some
pretty creative stuff in your day-to-day
er primarily a lot of problem solving
that that's really what it sounds like
now marcus thank you so much for joining
me i want to spend a few minutes also
about you and and you know who you are
behind you know the digital sales and
marketing expert
take me back to your childhood
before
the pool guy
what what really fascinated you as a kid
growing up
well i was really just a sports guy i
wasn't an academic
um
i
think i had a a grade point average of
2.3 in high school
and um
what i was though and i realized early
on
i realized i
communicated better than most around me
so i was the captain of the football
team i was captain of the baseball team
i was captain of the wrestling team
and i wouldn't say i was a great athlete
per se i was fine i mean i was
competitive
but i really
knew how to rally the troops if you will
right
and um
and that carried over to my
business life you know and today in fact
i spend probably about a third of my
time
teaching
just transformative leadership
communication communication skills in
general i think it's the greatest
skill
in the world and it's the most
underrated it's not taught in schools
for the most part it's not taught in
universities this is a tragedy
and it's something that i'm incredibly
incredibly passionate about and i'll
tell you just a really really quick
story people say well how did you know
you had this thing i knew i had this
thing
when one time i was done baseball
practice
and we were watching the girls softball
practice and they were finishing up and
they had their biggest game of the of
the season the next day
and as they were just winding practice
down
they were huddled up and one of them
looked at me and i was you know i was
standing you know next to the fence with
my fellow baseball players on the other
team
and uh their captain said to me hey
marcus why don't you come over here
and get us inspired for tomorrow
and uh so i was like okay yeah sure so i
just you know went over went over to the
uh to this group of girls and and uh we
got him fired up for the next day but
what stuck with me that night michael
was why did why did she ask me like what
did she why did she ask me
and um
and what i said to myself too was well
she asked you
and that means something and so you need
to develop this you need to take this
and run with it so that was the moment
when i realized i was supposed to be a
teacher a communicator a motivator if
you will i just happen to need to have a
story with it and that story was that of
a pool guy
amazing and i wish we could end it on on
this note but i have i have two more
questions that i really really want to
ask but that was really really an
awesome story and what inspires you
today marcus as you go day by day what
really inspires you
i'm most inspired today frankly
by
individual thinkers
people that can truly think for
themselves
they're not swayed by what they see
necessarily by the masses
they're not swayed by what they've
seen done before this applies to
business
to personal to professional
that they can truly
look at something and say you know what
that ain't right
or you know what i don't i don't think
this should be the way there's a better
way and then they act upon it they do
something about it i think that's a
beautiful skill i think it's an
underrated skill i think
we are teaching people not to think for
themselves and i think that's
problematic we need to we need to
promote free thinking i think that's
where discovery and beauty lies
amazing and what are three words you
would use to describe yourself
well one is a spanish word which is
animo and uh
i lived in chile for a couple years and
they the people there would say you have
so much animal and animal is like it's
like
enthusiasm
but it's it is
an infectious almost enthusiasm
so i would say that's number one for me
um number two would be teacher
um just because
i tend to explain things
in ways that almost anybody could
understand them
which is uh important to me
and the third one
um would probably
uh be
um
restless
i think uh i just i want to i want to
move i want to be in motion
and i can't sit and watch a tv show the
idea of just sitting and watching a tv
show
is i think my my greatest nightmare
well something that we both share marcus
thank you so so much and this was a true
pleasure and i learned a lot and and i
have a feeling that our paths will cross
one day again so thank you very much for
everything and stay safe and stealthy
thank you michael